l'effort vents et la poudrerie
ralentissent les déplacements y compris
ceux de la police de l'État de New York
une situation qui m'est à risque les
résidents
cette animateur d'une télévision locale
la constaté en début de journée
la gouverneur a présenté une mise à jour
elle a vise que la garde nationale est
déployée pour répondre aux urgences et
la fermeture de l'aéroport de Buffalo
l'interdiction de conduire est toujours
en vigueur dans cette ville située dans
le comté dernier en voir les rues
désertes les résidences semblent avoir
compris la mesure
ce responsable du comté à Visé sur
Twitter que les intervenants tentent de
se courir des personnes coincées dans
des véhicules ils travaillent aussi vite
que possible au total les autorités ont
confirmé des morts notamment au Kenza
dans le Kentucky dans le Missouri et
dans l'État de New York depuis mercredi
dans presque tous les cas des résidents
ont perdu la vie sur les routes bien des
américains devront passer Noël dans le
noir des centaines de milliers d'entre
eux sont privés de courant responsables
d'un fournisseur d'électricité prévient
que même les clients branchés pourraient
voir leur service interrompus
plus de 2000 volts supplémentaires ont
également été annulés perturbant ainsi
les déplacements de la veille de Noël
ici Mélissa François Radio-Canada
Montréal